new in theaters this weekend birds of
prey and the lodge what will you see
this is your weekend ticket can I help
you why yes yes you can I'm here to
report a terrible crime and what
terrible crime is that this one not to
be outdone by her now ex-boyfriend
Harley Quinn hits the theaters for her
own adventure in birds of prey and the
fantabulous emancipation of one Harley
Quinn or just birds of prey in this
spinoff of Suicide Squad Harley has
broken up with the Joker and ends up
teaming up with Huntress Black Canary
and Renee Montoya kind of feels like she
should have a superhero name to help
save a young girl with a hit put on her
by a villain named Black Mask this
movies for you if you're a fan of DC
comic films you love Margot Robbie's
portrayal of Harley Quinn or if you just
really oh sorry oh well yeah extra nerdy
note just came in and it says that Renee
does eventually get a meme and it's the
question
hello in the lodge a family trip doesn't
go as planned when two children are left
with their father's new girlfriend after
he's called back into work blood things
take a turn from the worst when they get
snowed in and the power goes out oh and
they discovered their dad's girlfriend
survived a mass cult suicide and now
she's literally haunted by her past this
movies for you if an r-rated horror
movie sounds good to you you're a fan of
the two directors previous movie
goodnight mommy or if you fear getting a
stepmom not me my stepmom is cool she
lets me stay up late and play that is
your weekend ticket what will you see
and come back next week first Sonic the
Hedgehog